I want to get away from discrediting my
opponent and get back to discrediting
why would she just call me gay
we're friends Chris he's not in the
arena waffles pancakes
both great breakfast foods who says you
got to choose I do I say so so pick a
side cuz it's about to get crazy in here
waffles pancakes it's debatable
bro waffle and I'm Pro pancake proud
waffle supporter flapjacks are the
essence of breakfast food the waffles
are the only way to use this quick
batter team pancake did you know the
waffle iron was brought over here from
France by Thomas Jefferson a founding
father and the third president of the
United States of America
there is simply no argument against that
it's presidential it's a nice fact you
came up with him and no idea you come up
with it it's a fact waffle is about
separation deconstructing the food and
appreciating the ingredients as they are
not about mixing and matching it's all
going in your belly man you want part of
the RIP to be crunchy and part of the
RIP to be soft
that's what bread products are all about
no way around it a waffle is a better
vehicle to to appreciate the topping and
also appreciate the the peace of
breakfast food itself all these
crevasses waiting to be filled and
what's more fun than filling a crevasse
you poured syrup on this the syrup pools
in these things they don't soak nicely
into the waffle you can put bananas in
there you can enjoy each little piece I
mean you could put a little house out of
it what are you doing play with your
food eat your breakfast bro just like
pancakes you can stack them typically
you don't because you normally just have
a one big old [ __ ] waffle you can
stack with berries whipped cream you can
also serve it with fried chicken I mean
come on tried to clean a waffle iron by
the way I have you've cleaned a waffle
iron there's the chicken look at that
camera and say you've cleaned a waffle
egg because it is the worst [ __ ]
thing on the planet you do have to have
a waffle iron to make waffles but then
you get to have a waffle iron and you
get to put so many other fun things in
that waffle iron
everybody's got a [ __ ] skillet
skillet listen Wow Wow
listen to this sorry everybody has a
skillet everybody has a waffle iron or
not the 1% there's a last time you made
yourself a waffle
boy it's been years but same for
pancakes
oh no I made a pancake slightly more
read see because it'll have a waffle
it's 18-49 there gold panning with a
couple buddies you just came out from
the east what are you gonna cook around
the campfire the 99% make pancakes okay
we make them in the forest we make them
in our houses we make some with our
friends and our family pancake is the
ideal food for the working man the
waffle might as well put Mitt Romney's
[ __ ] face on that thing man let's see
where can we associate waffles with
Belgium where we can we associate
pancakes with every country oh my god
that cannot be true that cannot be true
that can't be true there's lots of ways
to make a pancake you obviously just
don't know how to make panky or you
could make your best crispy pancake and
put that up against the best crispy
waffle I guarantee that waffle is gonna
it's gonna still have that crunch
Packers B is not a good thing early in
the morning when you're soaking
something it's Europe you don't be
crispy because it will not impact get
soaked then it'll just sort of pull
around ants on the outside which is the
idea no that's not what you want with
pancakes they're brilliant because you
can cook in effortlessly bananas
chocolate chips
pecans blueberries effortless yeah you
chop up a banana you throw it in you
don't need like two like can you wobble
it video you can embed fruits and sweets
inside a pancake you try and do that
with a waffle you are throwing away your
waffle iron like guaranteeing you have
to admit that the point of this is to
get the syrup in a in an edible way into
your mouth sometimes they eat waffles
with just butter
I don't always put syrup on there you
are a barbarian this morning I conducted
a Google search for fun pancakes
cool pancakes I conducted a four cool
pancakes I got a spider I got this thing
that isn't real whatever that is is fake
that is quickly made on a computer then
I googled cool waffles and it I came up
it came back with this I've never seen
this chart before he fabricated this
chart
waffles are the marie-antoinette
of breakfast foods yeah they are
aristocratic unnecessarily fancy too
expensive for the French people this
this is the bread that the French people
need if you're an outside dancer you're
a waffle man if you're an inside Soaker
you're a pancake lady when you have a
flapjack or you have a pancake you're
you're essentially saying I'm okay with
breakfast when you're having a waffle
you're saying I'm looking forward to
breakfast
you know the stuffability and that they
are a food of the people now we put out
a lot of points today and we talked
about continental breakfast but I think
there's one thing we can both agree on
better than pancakes and waffles
waterslides
and this is really hard to fault okay
well